what do you think um
is the biggest misconception about
lebron james for someone who's been in
the trenches with him
he's my favorite player ever so like you
know i i kind of feel like he gets a lot
of um
he lost in the finals
that's that's why people have that
stigma of him he is undeniably
like when you on paper this is the best
athlete
i don't think we've seen a better one
that can speak in public
uh
be great with his family give us a great
you know what i'm saying like
performance performance every night he's
never involved in no [ __ ] he's not
gonna get drunk the night before and
have a terrible game or something he's
not gonna give us uh
um
some like dirty plays like the worst
thing we had against lebron was like bro
why are you flopping and literally he
start flopping because he like bro
i got to get these free throws if these
people get in free throws like like bro
i'm really getting hit so he's like i'll
sell it for you since they can't see it
cause i'm so strong right y'all can't
see me getting fouled so i gotta go like
this to show y'all he just raked my arm
but it's like
besides that bro ron has gone out here
every night and played hard
you know of course he gonna have his
times he'd take off for a day or two
whatever i get it you get tired but
i don't know who's been more faithful to
their
just being disciplined to the game like
braun
knows every scheme knows every coach
knows every player he knows players in
college you know what i'm saying like
when we talking about [ __ ] like this
he's put together an amazing body of
work i'd say the misconception with him
is that them losses came
from a lack of what he's capable of
and it's not it's uh
i think his losses is just
his style
that's just how it goes because braun
plays it the right way at the end of the
game when mike says i don't even [ __ ]
what happens i'm shooting this shot
braun says
i'm gonna get to this spot and shoot but
if i get here and any one of them is
flinching off of their man i'm beaming
it to that man
and he'll be
and to be fair i mean look mike also
john paxton and steve kerr and you know
there's there was times where he did the
same thing so okay i thought he was
gonna say he's like you know mike did
that no no i'm saying that there were
there was time no no there was times
where he also you know
at the end of very important games
found the open man talking about steve
kerr john paxton you know those but i
think um
awesome
i think the luck